This
is the cow N.E.H. American English
dialect recordings collection
tape number thirty five
psi
be
you come into women.
To
examine twenty excuse me and if
you
want
to look again. Yeah look in the lot in
my book more than two for
own fifty four fifty fifty four people
in Louisiana the
day we go
and I want to be you
I see you
can actually come
and I really
wish I would
be yelling at
you I didn't want you to do that.
I just wish I didn't
know I have a dream
today
and I live because I'm going
to do that.
It does tend to
about what the
day
three now to do here.
I used
to
take
a shot.
I learned that day
this week. It
didn't top.
Fortunately
I can use that day I genuinely I
changed
the way.
I defer the time and I
live day to
day I live I do.
Before
I have a sick day in
my
life
during the
day I am going to
study after study
just to
get
to my family and
given that I
am waiting along with
me
and
told him
to
quit they tell
me to and
today live in
this
usually every day I
go abroad I
live
here I don't want
I will.
I didn't
say no
I didn't know the Bangkok thing I'm
going
to watch is Bangkok.
If
you do it in the bank.
It's like you
go
around. But.
The people who live in the
bank that is that that is rigged.
Sometimes they
hit the people in Egypt which I
sometimes
talk with that
more
people I don't like to
get
a
tune with the
story plays to the point of story Carol.
I did it with my mom of it kind of thing to
say and.
I shoot in autumn for many
people and if you believe me I
could be blinded my
plenty and lovely to meet you go
my autograph have to them. But they're not going to be a defense in the
United States to see if I
had to have a job about your home. You need a
P.C. and didn't have a people have to have
a good man I have my life
today and I'm going to happy and I didn't take money. I didn't take
anything that you did to me.
I taught myself with you don't worry about that I'm going to happen.
I didn't take your money and continue to
need to let me share much. And if they have
a party. They are going to take me
down room.
And talking to get it and that is happy.
And that I have to run to seventy. If you
have a job.
You have your house but you
need the money you need. If you
put going public on the dam. And you see if he can do
it then I would
be happy. I can't do it I my
family have a lot.
I would just tell mama to give it to
somebody they really. For
hospitals up to date they will allow anyone to look
at the to
meet my needs
and still say
that I
hope I live for my safety anybody.
Just remember.
Did you have a general in the center room and.
Kind of a home video half of the people died in
the person died and if you have
a child suppose
that you're going to get back a living off
of them in my flinty I'm going to have anything.
If I have I have my friends I'm doing
you have you in my shall we do
have and.
Can set up your room and aspect of
my family my real friends for two parties who have
no debt.
And any time he was. Acted on.
That is if I have a job on my couch and in
my pharmacy they're going to have me. They don't get
anything I do they don't care if any people talk about here you're
going to have
to take the children but they
don't they know.
Actually
he's the
son here. I
think
he's going to be going
live living.
We think
well
the kid.
I didn't think
can
they can have anybody if they get
that lovely. Yeah sure.
THANK YOU THANK YOU to them but nothing to me
and I'm very happy when
and tell you anything like that.